so Joe Biden recently put out his
climate change plan and clean energy
plan and he gave really a pretty solid
speech about it and I think it's
important to cover this stuff because
number one Trump's not really doing
policy and I do think it's important to
draw a contrast when one candidate is
calling an urgent press conference at
the White House and spending 52 minutes
I believe it was sort of erratically
miss reading attacks on Joe Biden from a
piece of paper whereas Joe Biden is
actually doing policy now I know that
some people in my audience are going to
be furious with me how dare I say that
Joe Biden's climate change proposal is
pretty good it's not the green New Deal
it's not Bernie's plan it's not a oh C's
plan or whatever the case may be you
know it let's analyze it critically and
understand what have been the climate
change policies of people who have been
presidents and by that standard this is
the most progressive climate change
proposal that if biden is elected would
ever be associated with a sitting
president of course you can find people
who have run who have had other
proposals which we might like better and
I'm including myself in that list but if
Biden gets elected this would be the
climate change proposal most to the left
of any previous president and that's I
think a really important thing to keep
in mind so we're taking a break from the
nonsense and the insults and the
hyperbole and the bragging of Donald
Trump and I need to do a better job of
when Joe Biden talks about policy and
puts out proposals I should talk about
it last time I did this I went into some
detail about Joe Biden's tax plan it's
pretty solid it does a number of
important things that progressives
should be happy about
despite Biden's reputation is not being
particularly progressive and so I'm not
going to redo the whole tax plan story
but Joe Biden's tax plan includes a
number of important provisions like
removing the cap on Social Security tax
above 400,000 a year in earnings that
raises a huge amount of money from
people earning above $400,000 a year
Biden
would propose or proposes eliminating
the stepped-up basis provision for
inheritances I explained that last time
I mean this is really significant stuff
in terms of the money it would raise
I won't redo the entire tax segment but
needless to say many in the audience
appreciated it some just came in and
said it's not as progressive as what
Bernie wanted okay let's now look at Joe
Biden's proposal on environmental
justice and climate change and clean
energy now off the bat there's a bunch
of sort of regular regulatory stuff in
the proposal which I'm not going to
spend a lot of time on but it does bear
mentioning which includes Biden would
establish an environmental climate
justice division in the Department of
Justice Biden would make environmental
justice a priority within the federal
government Biden would refresh the way
that and sort of rehash the way that the
EPA does compliance that stuff deserves
attention but I want to look at some of
the specific metrics and actions that
Joe Biden is included in his plan so for
example Joe Biden includes specific
water quality improvements just to pick
one thing that's in his climate plan and
if you look at this part of the plan
Biden actually discusses and addresses
specific chemicals that are too much in
our drinking water and he does it in a
way where he sees water not only as an
environmental issue
which it is but also as an economic
issue which it is he sees water as an
issue of social justice as well so I
think we should all be pleased that Joe
Biden is talking about water quality in
his environmental proposal in a way that
shows understanding of how water relates
to race class geography economics etc
etc remember Joe Biden said that he
would use the green New Deal as a
framework in thinking about what he
wants to do and you can identify many
things in his climate change and clean
energy proposals that are almost
verbatim from the green New Deal now
what's hilarious is when Biden put this
out
and people identified look this is like
straight out of Bernie's plan this is
straight out of green New Deal
there were people who previously were
criticizing Biden for not being
progressive enough who now are saying oh
look Biden copied stuff from Bernie and
the green New Deal
shouldn't we be glad to see Biden
adopting things from Bernie Sanders and
from the green you deal like if the
concern was that Biden wasn't taking the
green New Deal seriously enough
shouldn't we be glad to see elements of
the green you deal in Biden's proposal
and you can see these components in a
few different areas when you look at
Biden's plan for retrofitting buildings
and schools in a way that will be good
for the environment but economically
stimulative that's straight out of the
green New Deal
a lot of the other things Biden includes
in these proposals are pretty obvious
things but there are things that aren't
being done or at least not done enough
like for example more seriously putting
in place subsidies and rebates when
Americans upgrade to more efficient
sources of energy and better windows and
efficient appliances that's worthwhile
government spending now two days ago
Donald Trump attacked Joe Biden for
having an ambitious goal in his proposal
and the goal is Biden wants to be carbon
to carbon pollution free electricity by
2035 meaning by 2035 Biden wants the
country to be generating electricity
from sources that do not pollute from
the standpoint of carbon that's a huge
task but if the criticism here is that
Biden is too ambitious on climate and
clean energy I'll take it I mean look at
the Trump administration that's going in
the opposite direction wanting to loosen
emission standards for vehicles wanting
to rehabilitate coal we've had that for
three and a half years I'll take an
overly ambitious proposal from Joe Biden
any day and importantly one of the
things I like about this proposal again
is Joe Biden is connecting energy issues
to economics and social justice and race
and he's connecting environmental issues
to all
of those same areas so for example when
Biden talks about his proposal that by
2035 he wants to be generating
generating electricity from sources that
don't pollute from the standpoint of
carbon he specifically says let's do
this by creating jobs with this green
energy shift where we will look to HBCUs
historically black colleges and
universities for training and hiring etc
just one example so where I'm ending up
on this is if you know something about
Joe Biden you actually shouldn't be
surprised that his climate and energy
proposal is very solid Joe Biden
actually wrote the first climate change
mitigation bill in 1987 he tried it in
86 and it went nowhere in 87 it was
signed into law by President Ronald
Reagan and it's particularly
disappointing to see some leftists who
are framing Joe Biden as kind of like
reluctantly dealing with climate change
sort of Biden actually has been on this
for more than 30 years there's lots of
areas where Biden has not really been
great unless you look at the last 10
years if you look 25 years ago there's
areas where Biden was not so good
Biden's been on climate for more than 30
years he said he would use the green New
Deal as a framework for his proposal and
he did so let's criticize Biden where
it's warranted
let's criticize Biden where the
proposals he makes don't go far enough
and I'll be digging into that in more
detail probably next week but you know
the pretending that Biden is just a
center-right guy on every issue
including climate it's wrong and the
fact that Biden put out this proposal
reinforces the importance of trying to
take the Senate so that we can maybe
actually get some of these things on Joe
Biden's desk put him in a position to
have to sign stuff into law rather than
having this long list of proposals that
will never see the light of day because
Democrats don't control the Senate
anyway so for me it's reinforcing hey
Biden's actually been pretty good on
climate for a long time and number two
importantly the importance of the Senate
to actually get some of this stuff in
front of Joe Biden to sign let me tell
you real quick about one of our sponsors
cuts clothing they offer super quality
men's t-shirts and they're giving you 15
percent off when you go to david
pakman.com slash cuts that see UTS
because solid color t-shirts are a
really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe I think it's really
important not to overlook the value of
having t-shirts you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with our men's solid color
t-shirts so they actually put a ton of
thought into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts I've owned and they
look great this right here that I'm
wearing on YouTube is the split hem crew
neck t-shirt very soft fits me perfectly
it's the ideal length go take a look at
what they offer and once you have it you
are really going to see and feel the
difference their slogan is it's the only
shirt worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS